just to be a Christian now living in
Hollywood at any level anywhere on the
totem pole or in the industry it is such
a seductive place and there is so much
titillation everywhere I mean we call it
Gamora by the sea that it is to keep
your faith yeah
in that at any level yes can be very
difficult so I'm going to quote Mel
Gibson on this Jim from his experience
he says it's a lot easier not to eat
from the apple tree if you're not
standing in front of it you got to keep
moving and if faith is is it what it it
it's that way but you got to every
morning I got up at 5 30.
was trying to make it
and I was in Mass at 6 30 in the morning
that's part of it you have to have you
have to work on the spirit the spirit is
going to move the mental and the
physical
most actors just do the mental and
physical and then the other other ones
if they have a spiritual thing it allows
them to do whatever they want right